I am a bioinformatics engineer at
ancestry.com my background has always
been in in biotech and I tend to focus
on the engineering side of that problem
so I build data pipelines for scientists
as well as for production systems I've
talked to a few people who are working
in biotechnology could like a show of
hands of people who are working with by
all like biological data no one come on
really
all right well hopefully this talk is
interesting for you it's not it's more
engineering focus so hopefully I'll keep
you entranced does anybody does
everybody know what ancestor comm is I
see a couple of hands yeah okay cool I'm
gonna give you the background anyway
this is my like corporate obligation
slide here so ancestry.com is a family
history website they collect
genealogical records from a bunch of
different sources like census records or
military records or immigration records
put them in a big database and then our
users are allowed to search those
records to construct family trees so we
have over 20 billion of those
genealogical records for people to
search and our users have then taken
those to create over a hundred million
family trees on our website about seven
years ago ancestry ventured into the
consumer genomic space and we released a
DNA test where you spit in a tube and
send it into our labs and we'll give you
two main products there's actually more
than this but these are kind of the core
of that product the first is that will
give you an ethnicity estimate so will
tell you kind of like a breakdown of
where your lineage comes from in this
case you know this person has mostly
Eastern European DNA we render that on a
map to show the different areas where
you might find your origins the other
piece that we do is we provide a
matching algorithm that detects who else
you might match to you in our database
so you can see in this case right this
person has all these other people who
have also taken our test they've they've
gone through and pitch
product to the rest of their family
clearly because they have all both their
parents as well as sibling and this was
supposed to be more of a reveal but it's
in the title of my talk so it doesn't
have as much impact but we have over 15
million of those DNA tests right so when
you take this test here we search
through that database of people and
connect you to people that you're
related to and since this is a data
science conference I know the question
that's on everybody's mind which is 15
million DNA tests that seems like a lot
of spit so we do have a spit test I'm
here for you to provide this information
so that equates to about four thousand
eight hundred eighty three gallons of
spit which is kind of a hard number to
really like think about what that means
so I've also got you there that equates
to about 61 bathtubs full and that's
like an 80 gallon tub like filled to the
brim so you could actually probably take
more baths if you want and this is kind
of gross because we're all adults and
like who takes baths right like we take
showers right so this would also be a 38
hour shower in pure spit yeah I know you
weren't expecting this talk to be so
gross and I think like if anybody
remembers anything from this talk this
will be the slide the other thing to
mention here is that I did all of the
art work here in Google slides so these
are originals if I really proud of my
bath tub guy he looks like a little
dejected to anyway so I mentioned most
of the talk is going to focus on
production data pipelines
I'll tell I'll kind of clarify what that
means a little bit but I'm gonna try and
tell the story of our DNA pipeline and
kind of give the history of that
pipeline as well as the sort of
technical decisions that we made along
the way and how some of those were
missteps and how we kind of corrected
those and kind of give a bigger picture
of how implementing pipelines with
simplicity is kind of a is the ideal
approach so when I mean the production
pipeline I'm kind of trying to draw the
line between between these two groups
which i think is probably a relationship
at a lot of companies where you have an
R&D group who's focused on algorithm
development and building models I'm
guessing like most people
in here from the talks I've seen or more
on this side of the fence is that
accurate who's like doing more like R&D
type science work no okay there's some
people yeah
on the other side that we have like the
production engineering team who's like
taking those algorithms and models and
implementing them in a way that like
works at scale right so we need to okay
good yeah cool guys what's on people
from both sides so most of my background
is actually on the production
engineering side of things working with
biological data I've since moved into
the R&D side so I have a little bit of
both worlds here and actually like if
someone's looking for a talk to do who
like knows this relationship well I feel
like this would be like a really
interesting space to explore just like
from a you know I don't want to say
cultural but like how those two teams
interact I think there's a it's an
interesting kind of problem of like two
groups who have very niche areas of
expertise that have to work together so
this is the pipeline I want to talk
about as I mentioned when you spit in
that to you we get sent to a lab and we
have a third party lab partner that
processes all of those samples and then
they send us basically like a text file
that contains the DNA information and
that's literally just a text file and
it's a TCG's with an identifier attached
to it and that enters basically right
into the pipeline and I just generally
call it B pipeline because it's easier
and we have three main things that that
pipeline has to do the first is that
we've used some sample QC so we need to
make sure that like the sample didn't
you know get contaminated in the lab or
like when the person spit they spit
enough and we have enough data to
actually analyze it and then we run
those two core algorithms so we run that
ethnicity algorithm I mean we run that
matching algorithm those results that we
generate from that pipeline gets sent
off to a separate database that another
team manages and so this is kind of like
is maybe a little bit different than
people who work on typical production
systems think about where you you know
if you're working on a production system
you think about things like scale and
load is the issues that you're trying to
tackle this pipeline doesn't really
concern itself with load so much it's
more trying to beat the clock so every
day that lab is sending us data
we have a 24-hour window with which to
process that data and then deliver
results because otherwise we become the
bottleneck of that system and can get
caught behind and then customers get mad
because it takes you know months for
them to get their results after they've
spit in the tube that make sense kind of
I hope so jumping back to the beginning
of when this pipeline started it kind of
started like a typical bioinformatics
pipeline which is that it was a
Frankenstein mess of like pearl and
Bosch code as well as like a bunch of
research tools that were out in the wild
so we used two primary tools that are
actually just out of different
universities there's this admixture
algorithm which is what we use for our
ethnicity detection that's just a
supervised learning algorithm from
Alexander and then we run this germline
algorithm which which detects matches in
a group of people based on their genetic
data and that's out of the Gusev lab you
can tell which tools are the research
and academic ones because they get no
logo and I had to use courier to further
shame that tool so when we had this
pipeline pretty early on there was a
couple of big challenges that we had
with it the first is that we had set
this all up and it ran on a single
machine right and we realized like even
before we had launched the product that
that just wasn't going to be tenable for
a long term so we needed to find some
way to distribute that processing across
a bunch of different servers right which
is a common problem the other thing that
was really a driver for us like an
extreme motivator for us to make changes
to that pearl and Bosch pipeline was
that the germline algorithm itself has a
quadratic complexity to it and I'll
explain what that means and we'll dive a
little bit into how that matching
algorithm works at a very high level but
these were the two kind of core problems
that we were trying to solve as a
company once we had this kind of like
prototype pipeline that we then needed
to build into something that was more
like a production system so this is
going to be kind of like a poor man's
genomics 101 as well as like an
introduction
our matching out of the more excited
very high level everybody has two copies
of DNA one from your mom one from your
dad right and so that's represented here
sample a has you know dad's DNA mom's
DNA and sample B has my dad's DNA mom CA
right and what we're looking for and
matching is just sections of DNA that
are identical between those two people
which would indicate that they receive
that DNA from a common ancestor or like
a parent right so in this case again
it's kind of hard to see but you know
these two sections of DNA are identical
so we would identify those and then we
kind of sum up how much of that DNA is
shared between those two people and that
actually gives us an idea of how closely
related they are so if you think about
it if that amount you know this is a
simplification of it but if you had 50%
shared between sample a and sample B
that might indicate that it's either
like a parent-child relationship or like
a sibling relationship see it tells you
how far removed you are from those other
people so that hopefully a kind of quick
introduction to that it's basically like
a specialized like string matching
algorithm right we're trying to find
these common sections of strings between
two samples and this portion of the
algorithm is not particularly like
complex and from a computational
perspective it's it's actually pretty
quick
the quadratic nature of it comes when
the implementation itself behaves like
this so if you imagine that you had a
database of say four people which is a
much smaller than we have but it's
easier to visualize you need to draw
connections between all these samples so
we need to do that string comparison
between sample a B C and D right pretty
straightforward and if we we also need
to go through all the other samples so B
gets compared to C and D and then C gets
compared to D right and the germ line
algorithm works like this and it takes a
single input right so if you imagine
you're in a research lab that works
really well for you you have a bunch of
data that you've gathered and you just
want to run and find all the matches
between that data set for a production
pipeline this became really limiting
because we get the answers to all these
questions on day one and then we get
another sample that comes in right
that we need to perform matching on
right and the problem with this
implementation is that it then it has to
rerun all of those other comparisons
again to answer that one question so if
we wanted to find out we already know
who a B C and D match to and we just
want to find out if he matches to those
people we have to rerun all the
comparisons again so this is kind of
like if you know someone added a new
webpage to Google or to the Internet and
Google instead of just like indexing
that one webpage they just really index
the entire Internet right so like said
from a research side that algorithm is
actually like it makes sense and its
implementation but for our production
systems it wasn't going to work it
wasn't going to scale and we could
actually predict that this is a graph of
like the projected run times of that
algorithm and some of this is actually
the true thing so this is again on a
quadratic scale our head of science
Cathy ball used to say that she could
pick the day that she was going to get
fired because this would run over that
24 hour time limit and we wouldn't be
able to continue processing samples
anymore so this was a high priority for
the company and for the product as a
group so we made a decision that I think
a lot of companies made back in that
time which is this is right around 2012
and decided to use Hadoop so as I
mentioned we wanted we needed to solve
that single machine problem and that's
what Hadoop was doing for us right it
allowed us to take this problem and
parallelize it across a cluster of
computers and we went like all in on
this we took that whole entire pipeline
and rewrote it from scratch and it
actually took about a year of time to do
that implementation from the time that
we decided to pick that technology until
we had released it in production and
like said it it was a big investment you
can actually go online and there's talks
that dive a little bit more into how the
internals of that matching algorithm
work that are fascinating to look at in
this context the other thing is that so
we reimplemented that germline algorithm
in Hadoop natively and allowed it to
take two inputs instead so we could then
rather than having this like single
database of things we could say here's
the database of all the samples I
already know the answer to and here's
the new sample that I want to find
matches for right and so this creates
makes that problem be
linear instead of quadratic which is
great the other thing is that someone
decided to call this algorithm also
germline but with a J which is the by
far the most confusing part of this talk
for me I have to refer to this algorithm
as J German from here on out so I
apologize for that yeah anyway yeah I
think the J stood because it was written
in Java so so like I said this is great
it it really solves that scaling problem
for us as well as we have this
implementation that we don't have to
worry about that sealing of like getting
to the point where we it's gonna take
700 hours of compute time to process
60,000 samples and and like I said it
works so this is a graph of when we
released that product and you can see
the the quadratic nature of the run time
and then the drop when we release that
you can also see just how close we came
to the 24-hour mark of releasing this
which is a little bit terrifying and
this is actually it looks pretty flat
here but this is actually linearly
increasing in run time as well it's just
not zoomed out far enough so all of this
part of the story kind of predates my
time I started working on this
production pipeline team about two years
later and when I came in I thought that
this was going to be like like said my
backgrounds in biology I was like this
is like the the Burj Khalifa of like
biotech pipelines for me I was like this
is gonna be awesome I'm gonna finally
like use Hadoop and like work with this
cool dataset it's a you know probably
the largest set of genomic data that I
had ever worked on but when I came in
the implementation felt a little bit
more like this it was like still kind of
an impressive feat of engineering but
there was just like something
fundamentally wrong that analogy is like
really on the nose I apologize so I want
to walk through like what the problems
were with that pipeline right we had an
implementation that worked and it solved
our problem for us but there were other
issues that came with that so the first
thing I wanna talk about is like how
that pipeline actually ran these are
kind of made up times but I just because
I don't remember how that schedule
actually was Hadoop is a batch
processing system and I think a lot of
people you know run it on a schedule
right like you have a job and you want
to run it at every everyday at 12 p.m.
or whatever
is a pretty common pattern we were
actually using a tool from LinkedIn
called azkaban which runs like is
designed to run scheduled to do jobs and
so you know this is like how the flow of
the data went right at 4:00 a.m. the lab
would start delivering data and at 9:00
a.m. we would kick off QC and matching
it and so on and so forth
and scheduling has some inherent
problems one of which is that like you
you have to kind of over allocate your
time right so if we know that QC is
gonna take about two hours we want to
give it like a little bit of extra like
time to run so we actually had a cluster
of like 50 servers running to process
all of this data and as you can imagine
like any sort of like idle time is a
little bit wasteful the other thing
about batching is that in a production
system in particular the longer
something runs right the higher the risk
of failure becomes so if you have a job
that takes two hours to run like in this
case we're running our QC thing and it
it's supposed to take about two hours
and it fails an hour and 45 minutes in
that means we have to start all the way
from the beginning and we've just lost
an hour and 45 minutes of processing
time in this an example you can imagine
like matching takes six hours to run if
it fails five and a half hours in then
we're actually like bumping ourselves
back into the next day and we've already
lost that time so this has like a couple
of issues we end up kind of like also
getting uneven amounts of data from our
lab some days we'll get 20 samples other
days we'll get 5000 and so our days end
up looking more like this where we're
all sitting around in a room and I have
a team of five developers and rather
than writing code we're all talking
about how we're gonna run this schedule
for the day we have to figure out you
know we have we've received this many
samples last night or you know how long
is matching gonna take approximately
let's add a little bit of time and make
sure that we're not going to have that
thing fail or run into our ethnicity run
or whatever it happens to be and this is
like further complicated by the fact
that Hadoop kind of requires like a
little bit of like hand-holding in those
situations where you're having uneven
amounts of data right you have to kind
of twist the knobs a little bit and
adjust memory and adjust the number of
Matt
purrs and things like that so we're
spending a lot of time doing things that
I don't typically want a dev team
working on right it's like we're doing
more hand-holding of this pipeline
rather than trying to automate these
problems and find different ways to go
about them or even focus on other other
more important issues so those are kind
of like the inherent problems that we
had with Hadoop as a solution the other
thing that started to happen was that
ancestries DNA test started taking off
you can actually see you know there's a
couple of like little bumps and in the
amount of samples that were receiving
per day and this is is kind of like
ancestry became Orwell more specifically
I became a victim of ancestry success
here where we started kind of seeing the
properties of that pipeline kind of
stretch and we weren't able we were
realizing that we weren't going to be
able to run the pipeline in xx in that
24 hour window anymore and we found that
out some were in the middle of like 2015
where like really had started to take
off and so the nice thing is ruined
Hadoop right so we know that we have a
scaling problem and we're gonna run into
that wall so we can just buy more
servers and so that's what we do we use
we figure out that we're gonna need to
actually double the size of that cluster
if this rate continues to make it
through the end of the year to continue
that processing so I don't know about
you but typically if I asked for 50
servers and these servers were like 24
cores or something so that's like a
thousand cores you have to really
justify it and we could justified in the
sense that we could say you know it's
we're hitting this 24 hour window if we
want to keep running this product we
need to invest in it but they also
understandably wanted to see that we
were fully utilizing the hardware that
we had and that's where it became a
little more problematic so this is a CPU
usage graph of a like in the middle of a
German run it's like kind of an
interesting aside you don't have to
count them but each of these little
Peaks corresponds to each of the
chromosomes that we process so we
process one chromosome at a time
chromosome 1 is bigger than the other
one so it goes long anyway we only use
22 of the autosomal chromosomes
sorry nobody did biology so maybe this
doesn't make any sense
and then the end is kind of the reduced
up so this graph became kind of
problematic mostly because we were
trying to justify that we needed more
hardware and if you average this out it
turned out that we're only using about
30 to 35% of the CPU to solve this
problem so we're asking to double our
hardware when we are only currently
using about 30% or a third of what we
already had which again is an issue and
so we started to try and dive into this
problem and this is where I guess like
the complexity of Hadoop started to kind
of become a burden on us this is an
iceberg by the way so this is one of my
other art originals and it wouldn't be a
Tech Talk unless there's like some
iceberg imagery so the problem is we
were started looking at optimizing this
problem and the thing is we had a pretty
straightforward implementation of that
string matching algorithm in our
germline code and there wasn't really
much we could do like we can't change
that algorithm because like that's the
gold standard of how we perform matching
but we had this like whole other hidden
part of how Hadoop works and it was like
really hard to start debugging and in
diagnosing what was going on to cause
the CPU to be idle for most of the time
is it some problem with like how HDFS is
like delivering data do we need to tune
that is it like how Hadoop itself is
like partitioning the data across this
cluster for us and it became like really
hard to dig into those type of questions
and this gets further complicated when
we our R&D team had also been hardly
working away at that that was the wrong
phrasing for that working hard at
developing a new matching version so
they you know had taken some new
research and had tweaked this algorithm
for us and as you can imagine they have
their own implementation of this
algorithm and now we have ours and
they've made changes in their code base
and we have to you know then translate
those changes into this Hadoop
implementation and this actually ended
up taking about another six months of
work for us to do which is like an
immense amount of time given that like
so we've already invested that first
year to build this system and now like
the maintenance of
is starting to bite us as well and this
kind of like harkens back to that same
iceberg image where it's really hard to
develop things in Hadoop right we have
all of these other things other
components that we have to set up even
just to start developing in those
systems as well as like then then being
just like harder to test and debug and
like work in isolation with those
solutions and so this actually kind of
for me became like the straw that broke
the camel's back a little bit we were
taking so long to develop this algorithm
that it started to impact product type
long time lines where other teams are
ready to deliver this and we're just
waiting on us to finish the actual core
algorithm to deliver which is I mean not
a position that anybody wants to be in
and so with the sort of like combination
of these problems we decided we needed
to do something simpler which is when we
decided to switch to Python so at a very
high level this is kind of like the
pitch that I gave to I guess the company
as we decide made this decision about
why we wanted to do this and these are
probably pretty common explanations I
think of why you might choose Python for
a solution like this one is that it gave
us a common language with our R&D team a
lot of our R&D team was working in
Python as well as our but it gave more
of a possibility that we could share
code with them when they developed
algorithms or tools or whatever it
happened to be that we could then
leverage in our pipeline as everybody
here I hope knows we're at a Python data
conference there's like a rich data
toolset and language features isn't in
the language itself that make Python
well-suited for dealing with a data
pipeline and we wanted to be able to
leverage those tools in a cleaner and
easier way than what we could do in Java
this is actually like I think maybe a
common one that my one my co-workers
used to say this all the time that
Python is good glue and we're building a
pipeline which at the end of the day
really is that we're like taking
together different pieces of like
disparages technologies and kind of
changing them together with you know
hopefully like lightweight glue in
between and Python works really well for
that it's also allows us to you know do
an implementation in a different
language when we need something more
performant
and then the last thing is that it's
simplest like we it's simple right we
everybody knows that Python is a simple
language this helped us remove you know
all the complexity that we had in that
Hadoop system and instead just write
various basic Python code so I'll talk a
little bit more about how we like
actually do those things the first thing
that we wanted to address was we wanted
to move away from this like scheduled
and batch model and we used a technology
for that called celery has it so I was
actually surprised when I asked people
before who here has used celery okay not
as many as I thought as everybody has
anybody not heard of celery and you
don't have to be shy okay cool so I'll
give a lightweight kind of explanation
of what celery does celery like I think
most famously is used by Instagram they
use it as their back-end processing for
all of their like images filters as they
come through but celery works like this
you have a queue and a cluster of
workers and on each of those workers you
load up all of your code that you need
to potentially run and then to execute
that function or code in Python you just
send a message into the queue with the
function name and its arguments and
there's not much more to it than that
it's it's pretty straightforward
you know implementation of this it's
probably a common thing for people that
have used other like queue based
technologies like even like slurm or
other things like that that deal with a
you know some scheduler that reacts to
an event coming in and the other thing
that we did with this so this kind of
like makes it so that instead of like
waiting for data to come in or figuring
out when something finishes we then
react to that data instead and then
there's an event that happens when you
know matching finishes we send another
message back to the queue to move on to
the next step the other thing we do is
that we break this up into more of a
single sample processing sort of model
so instead of doing batches were
processing one sample at a time in each
of these functions and we also further
break that down into individual pieces
of those steps right so rather than
having like this QC portion of the
pipeline QC is really like three this is
again just an example about three
different func
that we run and so this solves that
problem of batching incurring risk right
so now if you know this validate step
fails for sample C for some reason maybe
there's like an integration with some
API that we need to call to validate and
it breaks the rest of the samples just
like continue marching on and finish
their work and we can retry that sample
and it also has a larger impact on how
much time is is taken away from other
things working right if we retry that
hopefully that function can run in just
a few seconds and we've only lost a few
seconds in the event of a failure and so
for the people that like this is also
very simple to implement and again it it
almost feels comically simple compared
to how you have to deal with a dupe if
you imagine in Python you just have some
function right and in this case again
these are contrived examples but we want
to see some sample and it's a Python
function we do something to check you
know call rate to make sure the sample
looks okay and that heterozygosity and
all these other things that again maybe
don't make sense to anybody and it's
code that we can run on our laptop we
can run it on a cluster and it's all the
same and that makes that much easier to
work with as well as like debug and
check for problems and optimize for if
we want to put this in a celery
application it's basically four lines of
code we create a celery application
point it to our queue we annotate this
method with a task which kind of wraps
that as a celery function and then if we
want to call it we just say call that
function and delay with the arguments
and that sends that message off to the
queue and then the workers can pick that
up process that data and you know they
can send back results celery also has
sort of built-in monitoring and
automatic retries for us it's a very
like full-featured sort of solution but
it also has a very sort of simple
architecture to it that it makes it
likes it very easy to work with so this
is continuing my sort of contrived
example this is a glass of water with a
physics-defying Ice Cube in it where we
now have like mostly our code so we've
moved all this other stuff into Python
functions and some C++ to optimize
certain parts of the pipeline and then
we have this like very thin layer of
celery that like we don't even really
have to think about from a performance
or debugging perspective it's just kind
of like the orchestration layer that we
use to submit these things to that but
it doesn't really interfere with how our
code runs so there's a lot less for us
to think about so that's kind of how we
solved this distribution problem right
we we now have a system that we can is
more event-driven as well as avoids this
batching problem and instead we have
like a bunch of tiny little functions
that run and we reduce the risk of
failures there so then we come back to
that other problem which was that
quadratic matching issue so we want to
move away from a Hadoop and we want
something that's hopefully a little bit
more efficient I think a lot of people
think about this is maybe an important
distinction to make we're often told
that Hadoop is a fast processing system
and it is right like the horizontal
scaling allows us to to take a problem
distribute it and then process that
problem quickly but it's also pretty
inefficient we're dealing with a lot of
layers of abstraction and it tries to
hide those pieces from us which is great
but it also makes it so that it has to
make a lot of assumptions about how that
data is run that is like maybe hard for
us to dial in so instead what we want is
something that's a little bit closer
than metal a little more optimized
ideally something that's written in C++
and it turns out that we already have
something that does that which is G
germline and G germline I kind of glazed
over is an open source project and so
what we really needed to do is go into
this open source code change it so that
the implementation allows us to pass in
two arguments instead of one so that we
can do our new samples compared to our
old and then we get a C++ implementation
of this algorithm that can run on in
Python code or Python code to implement
this is 10 lines to call sub-process dot
run and parse the output for it this
also has the added benefit that the
research team is also coincidentally
already using
the C++ code they've already implemented
that new matching version for us so now
our work to take that code from R&D land
into production is to replace an
executable and then test and validate it
and that's the extent of implementing
that new thing rather than this being a
six-months project for us so the other
thing is that this is now much more
efficient this is a cpu graph during a
germline run you can actually notice
that there's like a little bit of a gap
and that's just because we under
allocated the worker for this because we
were testing but this actually pegs the
CPU for the entire run of our matching
things and this isn't up being much
faster it's actually about 64 times
faster than the Hadoop implementation
was a job that used to take six and a
half hours and now takes six minutes and
if you're good at math we ran a fifty
node cluster this is so fast that we
don't even need clustering anymore we
could run this whole algorithm for all
the samples at the time on a single
machine because it's so efficient and
actually like we probably could still be
in a vertical scaling solution even with
fifteen million samples but we're
probably pretty close to that point
where we're hitting that 24 hour window
now so yeah this is much more effective
so you might be thinking yourself isn't
Python slow and I got this question a
lot as we tried to move into this
technology and I feel like our answer to
this should be the obvious one which is
yes python is a slow language and I'm
kind of cheating a little bit by saying
oh like we're switching to Python for
optimization purposes when really I'm
just like taking these core pieces and
moving them into C++ but I think that
like for 90% of the problems that we
deal with with data in particular the
language itself is not the limiting
factor for performance very rarely our
solutions and driven by like a language
itself and instead it's the
implementation that is slow and Python
is nice because it's so simple that it
allows us to clearly see those problems
and then address them in the
implementation rather than the you know
as a language thing we could do all of
this in Java but it would
a lot more code and we might then
introduce issues where our
implementation is slow and we wouldn't
see those things and I'll give some
examples of that or kind of try and
demonstrate that so we had about a
hundred and twenty five thousand lines
of java code in this hadoop pipeline
which is a ton when we migrated the rest
of this into Python we really had about
twenty five thousand lines of Python and
C++ code so that's a hundred thousand
lines of code that we don't have to test
we don't have to you know maintain for
updates and it's also just a hundred
thousand lines of code that we don't
have to like think about and like
mentally map as we try and understand
the system it's still a big pipeline but
it's much smaller and when we try and do
these changes as we move things into
Python we found that we were actually
writing things significantly faster than
they were written in Java across the
board and that's kind of a weird
animation the pipeline itself goes
anywhere from three to seventy times
faster for all steps in that pipeline so
the 70 times faster is actually just
taking a pure Java code a part of the
pipeline migrating into Python with
celery and nothing else it's just pure
Python and most of that optimization
came from realizing that we were using
the disk way too much for i/o operations
would realize we could move all of that
into these like handoff in memory
operations instead and it just became
much faster and and we wouldn't have
necessarily like seen that problem if we
were so distracted by the other hundred
thousand lines of code that we had to
deal with in that other system so
remember that like even though the
language can be slow it's really
implementations I think that often times
anyway are what's driving performance
for us and the other thing is that you
know this also scales so this is not a
great illustration of ass I apologize
but in the yellow here is when we had
this duple implementation and then in
the green is where we switched over to
Python and so you can see that that
trajectory of growth of this database
continued to just escalate and the
system just continues to work and scale
for that for us and and and do it at a
much more efficient and performant pace
what this light is oh yeah so
if this is kind of like my little
nuggets of pipeline wisdom for you to
take away from this I'm not sure I'm
doing on time okay so the first is this
that events are usually better than
scheduling there are some cases where I
think we need to do scheduling and
typically those are things that are like
based around time like where you need to
run a report for the day before or
something like that but usually it's
much more efficient and effective to
react to data as opposed to scheduling
around it the other one is to avoid
batching and this one also has some
caveats generally you know like say we
increased risk as we batch sample or
batch you know data together and if we
can like break those up and partition
them into smaller pieces we are less
likely to be impacted by failures there
are cases where batching is necessary
and a good example of that is like if
you're if you have a task that has a lot
of i/o if like if you're loading a model
or something like that and it takes you
know 30 seconds to load the model and
then ten seconds to process one sample
it's probably better to batch it like a
hundred samples together and process
them all at the same time that like will
you still want to try and queue the
batch size small but you might not want
to totally remove batching another one
is to share code I feel like and again
maybe this is not as applicable for
everybody but when you have these two
worlds of research and development and
production engineering there's often
this tendency to think that the code
that comes out of research can't be put
into production and there's some truth
to that like we need to be able to
validate that code and make sure that it
can handle production workloads and
stuff but I still think there's like
this incentive or this I don't know the
word is desire I guess to try and like
re-engineer everything for production
and instead I feel like if we instead
tried to build tools that met the needs
of both those teams we'd be much better
off just from a maintained
maintainability perspective this one is
kind of highlights what I said before we
want to focus on things that are
efficient in software and not just like
focus on speed as a metric if you focus
on efficiency speed will come with it
but if you end up focusing on just speed
you might end up you know this in this
case not using 60% of your CPU for a
process which can just be expensive
might not matter as much for you know
offline more like data science type
pipelines when in production systems is
gonna have a big impact and then the
last one is simplify simplify simplify
I'm gonna kind of close with this quote
from macho sokolovsky I don't know if
anybody knows who he is but he's a
fantastic speaker if you haven't heard
of him he's also very funny so one
question there's probably two questions
that have come to mind one which is
something that bothered me for a long
time is like why didn't we just change
our germline implementation in the first
place instead of doing this whole
rebuild of that system and I think this
quote speaks to that right we got so
enamored with a technology solution and
to solve our problem that we kind of
forgot about what the core of the issue
was or how to solve it in a quick and
easy way right and the thing is it's
easy to be sort of blinded to what that
problem is when the solution that you're
implementing works right we can't say
that Hadoop didn't work it did we we had
great benefits from it right but at the
same time it was just kind of like an
ill-suited solution for our problem the
other thing is that you're probably
wondering like this seems like it's a
talked a lot about Hadoop like I don't
really care and Python is a simple
language and has simple tools like why
do I need to worry about this and I
think to some extent that's true right
Python as one of its tenants of the
language is simplicity right so we can
say that we have some inclination to
move away from complex tools but they're
still out there and if you look at like
the Python data science ecosystem I
think you can see that too even if we
have a bunch of different tools that
allow us to do our job and most of them
are simple we're still kind of like
inundated with choice and it's sometimes
tempting to pick a tool that is more
interesting rather than focusing on one
that is the simplest solution for our
problem yeah I think that's it
I just wanted to call these people real
quick this is the team that mostly did
this implementation
get the pleasure of presenting it but
they this is members of both the
pipeline engineering team as well as the
R&D team who did a ton of work to make
this implementation happen that's it
yeah questions what every good
microphone to you I'm just curious to
know if you guys took any stab at
optimizing the core algorithm may be
using some hash sets or yeah so I really
glazed over a lot of detail there the
algorithm itself will so me answer that
first part of that question
on the production engineering side of
things we we tend not to worry so much
about the implementation of the
algorithm itself because we can't really
change the the how the algorithm works
right like it's not our job to determine
what might determine a match between two
people so we try to focus not on those
problems we do like read the code and
like look at optimizations but it's we
can't really like flip the algorithm on
its head and produce like good but not
the same results like it's our job to to
create parity with what the R&D team
produces the algorithm itself is like
really optimized we do it does actually
do hashing across all those things to do
lookups so the first step of that
algorithm is to build a hash table
across all of the samples this is
actually like an interesting aside we
actually were using HBase to store those
precomputed hashes for all those
locations so that we could quickly look
up locations where they matched in the G
germline implementation of that we
didn't do that because it was actually
turned out to be slower to retrieve
those things over the network than it
was just recalculate them so if there
are talks online and we actually
published both white papers for our
ethnicity as well as our matching
algorithms and a couple of other other
elegans so if you're interested in how
those work there they're all publicly
available but yeah they they are fairly
optimized the algorithm itself does run
quite quickly we do you know like said
read the code to try and find any like
sort of obvious like errors that might
happen but our R&D science team is
like a bunch of pretty smart people too
so like usually they have done a pretty
good job actually for their C++
implementations anyway so thank you for
sharing I have question about salary I'm
not very familiar with salary but did
you also try the using a desk or
comparing the performance between desk
versus salary we we didn't so I think so
desk and I haven't actually used desk I
only know lightly what it is desk is a
distributed pandas dataframe and my way
off base there oh you could like
calculate something from when no to and
to another passing the value from one
node to another there is similar with
salary I think yeah so I mean I think
they do have different goals and it's
celery likes that doesn't have anything
to do with the computation on the data
itself it's really just like a way to do
almost like remote execution of a
function on a cluster right so that you
solve different problems we haven't used
tasks I think like that might come back
to that same problem where if we wanted
to use a technology like that it might
require reimplementation
to put it on that technology which is
something that might like be a good idea
but is also something we might try and
avoid we haven't tried that as a
technology I do think they're like their
goals are slightly different but I also
haven't tried it so I'd be curious to
talk to you more about it like said of
my my knowledge of tasks is apparently
like zero so okay thank you because I'm
also not familiar with salary but maybe
I think they're very seeming because in
desk
you also could like do the petition and
calculate in parallel also passing value
from one task to another okay yeah I
mean like said yeah come talk to me cuz
like I said I don't know enough and
maybe we can bridge that gap there I I'm
not sure did you have to so here your
sample was all specific genome correct
yeah and so you had many million samples
but then
and you talked about computation on
those things like for example computing
relationships and so on
yeah did you use a similar pipeline for
that as well or was the previous
structure which you had to process that
data somewhat better so you so if like
for instance finding relationships
between multiple samples right right so
the kind of processing you would need to
do there is going to be different so
that's where you're gonna share
information between two nodes and so on
right yeah so the again there are pieces
that I glossed over on this a little bit
so we if you think about like that
matching question for us like it's
really like it's not that we want to say
does this one sample match to 15 million
people we want to say just like person a
matched person B and we want to get that
answer and then send it off and so we
really like don't attack that problem as
if it was a whole database that we
needed to get one answer out of it's
like we have 15 million questions that
we need to ask and 15 million potential
answers out of that and so it doesn't
really like I guess require internode
sort of communication we're really just
like loading up what actually amounts to
like a very small amount of data between
two samples and then processing them
there are some pieces that we do change
and again that we do actually batch
together at a small scale to avoid i/o
challenges if you think about like if we
got a thousand samples in a day and we
wanted to do one at a time against that
whole database that means that we'd have
to load the 15 million people a thousand
times and so instead we do like kind of
these micro batches where we do a
thousand people against a thousand
people and then that in that case we
would only have to read that database
once to do that but we only get man
about a math 150,000 no don't have
15,000 like computation things we have
to do but there's not like a need for
any communication doing those notes one
more thing like is that representation
here I'll simply call graph databases
here or is it something else it's ya
know so well we actually for the storing
of the results is like and that's
another team sort of responsibility we
just write those out in flat files and
then they get put into a database we
don't
I only use a graph database but it is
something that we've thought about
exploring the on the aren't D side we've
talked about a lot more because we're
doing certain things with that the
output of all of those matches like
we're running the vein community
detection on those as well and like
loading that up into a graph database is
really helpful for us to do that
research but currently but that this
pipeline is literally just dumping a
flat file out and then like pushing that
into an API and then that gets ingested
into a dailies but it's not a graph
database right now as any part of this
the the Python implementation and it's
germline with a G yes any of it open
source or anything we can play with at
home yeah so germline with the G is open
source admixture is not it's also not
the algorithm that we use anymore we
switch to a custom version of of an
ethnicity detection algorithm and that's
not open source either unfortunately we
do have the white paper which you could
read through and it actually goes
through a lot of detail about how that
it works and that actually is using a
hidden Markov model for that
implementation admixture itself like
said is closed source and I think there
are some open sourced like recreations
of admixture but not the core algorithm
that we used
but yeah Gigi remind is open source and
and it's like not an unmanageable
codebase we we have like slimmed it down
and like said it's just string matching
essentially and it's I think it works
out to something like 600 lines of C++
so it's not a daunting sort of
implementation for us okay thank you
yeah simple to you applies well data
gotta do that the same adult you know
algorithm yeah so we you would actually
come up as like a twin to yourself you
can like submit multiple kits to a
single account and we don't distinguish
between those two things so you would
well so I shouldn't say that you
wouldn't get exactly identical results
because like some of those learning
models are you know there's the
potential that you're gonna have like
missing data in certain locations and
things like that
I think like for matching you should
probably get almost identical results
for some people get you know like
literally hundreds of thousands of
matches as they take after they take
this test and you might like lose a
couple of like the really distant ones
or something like that
but in general they should be saying we
have like a quality control that that
requires that the data you know have a
certain like week you have a certain
missing this rate that we don't accept
and things like that so ideally they
should be so you have the same plus sent
to you in different time and then when
you run through the algorithm like a you
this you have to input wines the
original date saga your original data
training results from previous day and
then you have loose impose out that yeah
yeah yeah yes a lot that question we do
there I mean there are a bunch of like I
guess complicating factors the
technology has evolved over those seven
years so the people that took the test
in you know 2012 get a slightly
different set of genotype data than the
one but actually for matching we have
kept that the set of the genome that we
use for matching is consistent across
all of those versions so it shouldn't be
but again like there could be like the
technology might be better at one
location you know in 2012 that it is
today or vice versa and so there's like
a little bit of variance that might
happen there okay yeah
okay team warm thanks so much yeah
thanks guys
[Applause]
[Music]